there's an assumption at large that
sexiness is at heart about nakedness and
explicitness and that logically
therefore the sexiest scenarios must
also be the ones involving the greatest
amounts of nudity but the truth about
excitement is rather different at the
core of sexiness is an idea the idea of
being allowed into someone's life when
the memory of having been excluded from
it is at its most vivid sexiness stems
from a contrast between prohibition and
acceptance it's a species of relief and
thanks had been given permission to
touch and go anywhere oddly this
gratitude is likely to be most prevalent
not when one's been granted full licence
by someone but when one is on the
borderline when one's only just been
lent a pass and when the memory of the
taboo nature of touching others is still
intense the reminder of the danger of
rejection brings the Wonder are being
included into sharp ecstatic relief this
explains why the decision to keep one's
clothes on a bit longer than strictly
necessary to deliberately keep clothes
on during sex can prove such a turn-on
to heightened excitement we may design a
scenario in which we are allowed only to
press against one another never moving
beyond guilty caresses in small thrusts
like we might have been forced to do in
early adolescence or in a nunnery in the
1300s such games mean we can keep
revisiting the incredible idea of
permission the outer garments evoke the
barriers once finally been able to cross
with impunity we are via the game trying
to get over a Croma around exclusion
once we're used to being undressed
around someone the wonder they've
allowed us into their lives is liable to
get lost and taken for granted the game
of keeping one's clothes on tries to
keep the interest of nakedness alive by
drawing attention to its privileged and
intimacy the game symbolizes a poignant
celebration of the
beauty of being at last granted
permission
you